bonsoir emmanuel dupuis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
anthony blinken juste après un job
hayden cette tournée européenne est ce
qu'elle montre que le nouveau président
veut à tout prix renouer les liens forts
avec ses alliés européens
oui mais comme le vôtre reportage
démontre parfaitement il vient quand
même néanmoins une différence d'approché
entre la france et l'allemagne
en ce qui concerne la relation avec les
états unis et il y a aussi une volonté
pour le président aimait raconte de se
réapproprier des dossiers en matière de
politique étrangère qu'ils ont un petit
peu éloigné de la scène
précisément puisqu'il n'avait pas pu
rencontrer ses homologues il a rencontré
la nuit là il a pu bénéficier pardon du
premier dîner en présentiel comme on dit
désormais avec la chancelière merkel
la conférence de berlin qui s'est tenue
il ya quelques heures a bien montré
aussi que la position française est unie
et peut-être qu elles divergent un peu
des positions américaines en tout cas il
y a une volonté de la part de la france
de dire qu'évidemment elle se réjouit du
multilatéralisme actifs ou coopératif
comme le dit emmanuel macron mais qui a
sans doute peut-être des dossiers sur
lequel il y a des lignes un peu plus
divergentes qu'elles ne sont
convergentes
alors effectivement depuis berlin
anthony blinken a aussi martelé que les
états unis n'avaient pas je cite deux
meilleurs amis dans le monde que
l'allemagne rien que ça paris appréciera
ça dit quoi précisément cette
déclaration on parlait de points de
convergence avec l'allemagne y en a
tellement qui diffère avec leur la
france passé du tout c'est évidemment ce
que ça veut dire c'est que la puissance
économique du monde est supérieure à la
puissance économique française et que la
mobilisation des etats-unis vis-à-vis du
continent européen et davantage
économique année stratégique
les premières visites du président wade
n ont pas été pour l'europe mais tu
présentes à gan et du ministre de la
défense ainsi que du secrétaire d'état
l'ont été pour l'asie et que le regard
que les états unis ont vis-à-vis de
l'europe c'est avant tout un marché
est un marché pour ces compagnies et de
ce point de vue les états unis ont
disons diplomatiquement regarder avec un
peu de préoccupations la manière dont
les européens entendent taxer leurs
bibliothèques donc la principale
entreprise du numérique mais en même
temps les lequel quand il évoque que le
fait que l'allemagne est le meilleur
allié des états unis a en tête bien sûr
le fait que l'allemagne a aussi un autre
allié économique dans son voisinage
immédiat qu'est la russie n'en seraient
les deux étant peut-être la ligne de
faille ou la ligne de fuite sur lequel
les américains entendent ré engager un
dialogue avec là aussi a fait perdre
avec l'allemagne les etats-unis n'ont
pas pu empêcher en galets merkel de
terminer les quelques 170 km qui reste
du de cet oléoduc
mais on voit bien que les américains
souhaitent aussi réengager le dialogue
avec l'allemagne sur un plan économique
et peut-être plus symboliquement avec la
france dans les espaces qui constitue sa
profondeur stratégique la méditerranée
l'afrique est bien évidemment parmi
cette zone le sel alors en même temps on
souligne évidemment comment ne pas le
souligner que entonné dean cain est un
francophone et francophile il a même
grandi fait ses études à paris ça va
forcément peser un d'ailleurs jean yves
le drian et anthony blinken se
connaissent déjà très bien oui alors je
suis pas tout à fait totalement d'accord
avec 7,7
cette version des choses évidemment tony
blinken a passé ses humanités partie des
humanités comme on dit en france ça ne
veut pas forcément dire que la totalité
de la diplomatie américaine et
francophile et encore moins francophones
ensuite la position américaine est une
position vis-à-vis de la france qui est
un petit peu celle que récuse et le
général de gaulle
c'est à dire m alignement ou du moins
une proximité qui v qui fait que les la
francophonie rejoint la francophilie
quand l'un à jandun diplomatique des
partenaires est totalement alignée à
celui des américains je ne suis pas tout
à fait certain que vis-à-vis de la
turquie ce soit
aucun je suis encore moins convaincu que
ce soit le cas sur d'autres dossiers
notamment la reconstruction en syrie où
il est vraisemblable que les états unis
entendent dialoguer avec leurs autres
partenaires
la turquie qui est pas forcément le
nôtre donc la francophilie et la
francophonie du secrétaire d'état est
une avancée mais je ne suis pas certain
que hélas le passé nous le prouve que la
leur aux pénalités si j'ose m'exprimer
ainsi d'un certain nombre de secrétaires
d'état avant et était consubstantielle
d'une politique étrangère plus
conciliante vis-à-vis de la france où
vis-à-vis de l'europe les etats-unis ont
été très clair lors du g7 de carolis b
il ya de ça deux semaines bien sûr que
un certain nombre de sanctions qui ont
été mises en avant par le président
donald trump vis-à-vis de l'aluminium
taxation à 25% de là c'est à dire pardon
glaciaire 20% de l'aluminium à 10% et
est un très mauvais signal par rapport à
cette amitié je suis pas du tout certain
que la concurrence très vigilant tout
très ferme très active entre boeing et
airbus même si on n'a évidemment pu
obtenir
contenir la chine s'il fallait trouver
une légitimité à l'otan c'est évidemment
le contexte de l'union soviétique
peut-être un peu moins de la russie mais
ça reste évidemment un départ internes à
l'organisation en tout cas là il ya une
vraie divergence par rapport à la
manière dont les états unis va nous
engager dans une confrontation binaire
où est-ce qu'on se lève contre hausse de
2 lié à une confrontation pardon direct
vis-à-vis de la chine évidemment les
états unis souhaitent avoir des
partenaires en dans la zone indo
pacifique où évidemment là où la
confrontation et géographiquement la
plus évidente ou en tout cas là la moins
évitable c'est à dire dans le nord-est
de l'océan pacifique
mais je ne suis pas du tout certain que
ce soit à l'otan de 2,10 procédé je suis
encore moins certain que à force de
diluer les responsabilités de l'otan qui
est avant tout une invitation de
sécurité collective et non pas une
association un peu fourre tout dans
lequel le président américain voudrait
mettre où il remettre une sorte d'agent
d'un des démocraties occidentales
là-dessus la france je crois divergent
un peu sur l'idée que ce ne serait que
des démocraties occidentales qui
pourraient guider pour guider le monde
vers cette aspiration que le président
joe biden a lui même évoqué dans un
article qui est paru dans le washington
post il ya trois semaines
je suis absolument convaincu que là il
ya sans doute une exigence de la part de
la diplomatie française et qui je crois
est une et conductrices depuis quelques
mois du président français